I need someone to get my hour Nick Jonas  and Priyanka Chopra engaged  [Music]  it seems the couple is taking their  relationship to new heights according to  multiple reports Nick and Priyanka are  set to tie the knot after only two  months of dating  I am very romantic at heart and I think  if you care about somebody there's  nothing wrong in making someone feel as  special as you feel like they are in  your heart  earlier this month et caught up with the  Quantico Star just one week before her  birthday where she gushed about being a  hopeless romantic her 25 year old beau  reportedly popped the question on  Priyanka's 36th birthday while the  lovebirds were in London my birthday  wish this year would be what it is every  year for like the next year to be even  better than it was last one but my wish  is usually very simple and what I'm  doing for my birthday is I'm going for a  secret getaway baked crab et has reached  out to the couple's reps for comment  [Music]  [Applause]